hello everyone so what I'd like to do
here is describe how we think about
three dimensional graphs three
dimensional graphs are a way that we
represent a certain kind of
multivariable function the kind that has
two inputs or rather a two-dimensional
input and then a one-dimensional output
of some kind so the one that I have
pictured here is f of XY equals x
squared plus y squared and before
talking exactly about this graph I think
it'll be helpful if by analogy we take a
look at two dimensional graphs and kind
of remind ourselves how those work what
it is that we do because it's pretty
much the same thing in three dimensions
but it takes a little bit more
visualization so with two dimensional
graphs you have some kind of function
you know let's say you have f of X is
equal to x squared and anytime that
you're visualizing a function you're
trying to understand the relationship
between the inputs and the outputs and
here those are both just numbers so you
know you input a number like two and
given it's going to output for you know
you input negative one it's going to
output one and you're trying to
understand all of the possible
input/output pairs and the fact that we
can do this that we can give a pretty
good Intuit intuitive feel for every
possible input output pair is pretty
incredible and the way you know the way
we go about this with graphs is you
think of just plotting these actual
pairs right so you're going to plot the
point you know let's say we're going to
plot the point two four so we might kind
of mark our graph to here 1 2 3 4 so
you'd want to mark somewhere here 2 4
and that represents an input/output pair
and if you do that with you know
negative 1 1 go negative 1 1 and when
you do this for every possible input
output pair what you end up getting and
I might not draw this super well it's
some kind of smooth curve and the
implication for doing this is that we
typically think of what is on the x-axis
as being where the inputs live you know
this would be we think of it as the
input 1 and this is the input 2 and so
on and then you think of the
output as being the height the height of
the graph above each point but this is
kind of a consequence of the fact where
we're just listing all of the pairs here
and now if we go to the world of
multivariable functions here I'm not
going to not going to show the graph
right now let's just think we've got
three dimensional space at our disposal
to do with what we will we still want to
understand the relationship between
inputs and outputs of this guy but in
this case inputs are something that we
think of as you know a pair of points so
you might have a pair of points like one
two and the output there is going to be
1 squared plus 2 squared and what that
equals is 5 so how do we visualize that
well if we want to pair these things
together the natural way to do that is
to think of a triplet of some kind so in
this case you'd want to plot the triplet
1 2 5 and to do that in three dimensions
we'll take a look over here
we think of going 1 in the x-direction
this this axis here is the x-axis so we
want to move a distance one there and we
want to go 2 in the y-direction so we
kind of think of going a distance to
there and then 5 up and then that's
going to give us some kind of point
right so we think of this point in space
and that's a given input output pair but
we could do this for a lot right a
couple different points that you might
get if you start plotting various
different ones look something like this
and of course there's infinitely many
that you can do and it'll take forever
if you try to just draw each one and
three dimensions but what's very nice
here is that here I'll get rid of those
lines if you imagine doing this for all
of the infinitely many pairs of inputs
that you could possibly have you end up
drawing a surface so in this case it the
surface kind of looks like a
3-dimensional parabola that's no
coincidence it has to do with the fact
that we're using x squared + y squared
here and now the input the inputs like 1
- we think of as being on the X
why plane right so you think of the
inputs living here and then what
corresponds to the output is that height
of a given point above the graph right
so it's very similar to two dimensions
you think you know we think of the input
is being on one axis and the height
gives the output there so just to give
an example of what what the consequence
of this is I want you to think about
what might happen if we change their
multi variable function a little bit and
we multiplied everything by half right
so I'll draw it in red here let's say
that we have our function but I'm going
to change it so that it outputs one half
of x squared plus y squared what's going
to be the shape of the graph for that
function and what it means is the height
of every point above this XY plane is
going to have to get cut in half so it's
actually just a modification of what we
already have but everything kind of sh
loops on down to be about half of what
it was so in this case instead of that
height being five it would be two point
five you could imagine let's say we did
this you know it was even more extreme
instead of saying one half you cut it
down by like 112 maybe I'll use the same
color by one twelfth that would mean
that everything you know she loops very
flat very flat and close to the XY plane
so a graph being very close to the XY
plane like this corresponds with very
small outputs and one thing that I'd
like to caution you against it's very
tempting to try to think of every multi
variable function as a graph because
we're so used to graphs in two
dimensions and we're so used to trying
to find analogies between two dimensions
and three dimensions directly but the
only reason that this works is because
if you take the number of dimensions in
the input two dimensions and then the
number of dimensions in the output one
dimension it was reasonable to fit all
of that into three which we could we
could do but imagine you have a multi
variable function with you know a three
dimensional input and a two dimensional
output that would require a five
dimensional graph but we're not very
good at visualizing things like that so
there's lots of other methods and I
think it's very important to kind of
open your mind to what those might be
in particular another one that I'm going
to go through
soon lets us think about 3d graphs but
kind of in a two-dimensional setting and
we're just going to look at the input
space
that's called a contour map a couple
other ones like parametric functions you
just look in the output space things
like a vector space you kind of look in
the input space but get all the outputs
there's lots of different ways I'll go
over those in the next few videos and
that's three dimensional graphs